رغم اقرار الداخليه التركيه بمنع دخول اي
مواطن الى هذه البنايات المهدمه لكنهم ومع
هدوء الارض من الهزات الارتداديه يسارعون
الخطى لاقتناء واخراج مقتنياتهم او ما
امكنهم من اخراج ذلك
مرحبا شيخ مرحبا
ايش تعملوا من نزل البيت الاغراض البيت
القديم لتحت الجديد
خطر اعتقد انه البنايه البنايه قائله
للسقوط صح اي نعم
لكن كان في قرار السلطات بانه يمنع اي
واحد
بيدخلوا
من البيت هذا هذا الممنوع الدخل اما هذا
هذا كويس عن هذا
اضرار خفيفه مش مش كثيره نعم
ما نحسن نفوت لجهوده اما ادرار الكثير ما
محل
هون هون
يعني هناك
بحذر يقومون باخراج اغراضهم خوفا من حدود
زلزال اخر او هزه قويه قد تاتي على هذه
البنايه وما فيها من اغراض
يعتبرونها كل ما تبقى لهم من ذكريات قبل
ان يضرب الزلزال هذه المناطق عبد القادر
خربوش في قناتي العربيه والحدث من ضاحيه
سمنداغ ولايه هاتاي جنوب تركيا